[Musique]
leonard cohen a chanté l'amour
passionnément et la vente par la maison
christie's d'une cinquantaine de lettres
adressées à sa toute première muse qui
lui entre autres inspiré la chanson so
long marianne ne fait pas la faire de
cette spécialiste de l'oeuvre de cohen
leonard cohen qui était quelqu'un de
très modeste voire ses papiers vendues à
des collectionneurs privés
bah c'est quelque chose qui est assez
scandaleux oui je suis plutôt content
mais je suis en fait comme plusieurs
personnes qui font de la recherche
sérieuse parce que c'est un patrimoine
littéraire mondiale qui devrait être
accessible à tous pour la petite
histoire bien des années avant de faire
son premier disque le nul couronne tombe
en amour avec la norvégienne marianne il
n en 1960
tous les deux se trouvent sur l'île
grecque d'hydra un endroit prisé par les
poètes
il y avait un jeune enfant leonard cohen
tombe amoureux d'elle et la trouve très
très belle trouve que les unes des plus
belles femmes au monde
dans le cas de bernard cohen et une
marianne il n c'est une grande île qui
les a marqués dans leur jeunesse
marianne il n a été en contact régulier
avec le poète pendant dix ans on la voit
justement à l'arrière de la pochette du
deuxième album de cohen paru en 1969
le couple est devenu mythique est un
film sur leur histoire sera présenté au
cinéma d'ici la fin 2010 9 20 que
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est là où leur amour est resté très
romantique c'est qu'il a dans la mémoire
de tous les deux il a quand même survécu
au temps et pour lui elle a toujours été
une de ses muses favorite accessible en
ligne
la collection de lettres vendue chez
christie's provient de la famille de
maria nylén décédé il ya deux ans dans
ces lettres écrites sur une période de
20 ans on découvre les notes court
amoureux parfois déçus et plein d'espoir
alors qu'il signe son premier contrat de
disque c'est ça qui est un désastre
parce que c'est comme dans les
collections des grands artistes dès
qu'on divise une collection pour les
vendre à gauche et à droite on perd le
sens de l'oeuvre
cet autre spécialiste de l'oeuvre
aimerait que ces lettres se retrouvent
dans les archives la nôtre cohen de
l'université de toronto
car avec cette vente aux enchères mais
porte qui pourra les acheter
[Musique]
la vente de ces lettres doit débuter le
5 juin en attendant on peut les lire
peut-être pour une dernière fois sur le
site de l'encanteur
ici oui mais radio-canada mort hier
[Applaudissements]